we begin in indonesia with the first
sign of the submarine which has been
missing for days
search teams have recovered debris
believed to be from the vessel
the military chief said that scans
detected the
sub at a depth of 850 meters
it's calculated that its oxygen supplies
ran out several hours ago but
the navy said it would continue to
search for possible survivors
53 crew members were on board let's go
live now to jakarta
al jazeera's jessica washington is there
the military was giving a press
conference which
uh ended a few moments ago jessica what
did we learn
well adrian military officials described
these latest developments
as deeply concerning the debris you
mentioned they
discussed what exactly was found and
they've
also declared that the status has now
changed
from submiss to sub sunk now some of
that debris includes the
torpedo launch pipe a plastic bottle of
grease which is used
for the periscope korean debris with
some korean writing because this
submarine was refitted in south korea
and returned to indonesia in 2012.
sponges used to clear condensation and
also items used for prayer now
now that the status has officially
changed to sub
sub sunk authorities say they are deeply
concerned about these developments
because
the fact that they have found this
debris in this area this search of the
bali sea
indicates to them that there are cracks
in the hull
of the submarine as it sunk into deep
waters now
they do say that they are going to
persevere with this effort
this effort involving uh 16 indonesian
navy vessels
and an australian navy ship as well they
are continuing to search this area
and making preparations for medical
evacuations
as you mentioned oxygen supplies on the
ship
on the submarine may have already
depleted
in the case that there was a total
blackout on the submarine
authorities say they can't rule out that
there may be a possibility that there
might not have been a blackout and in
that instance
there should have been enough oxygen on
the submarine for five days now
authorities are being very careful to
stress that this is a very serious
situation
but they say at this point they cannot
comment on the 53 crew members and
whether or not they are still alive
all right for the moment jessica many
thanks indeed jessica washington
reporting live from jakarta